c'était l'heure de la reprise pour les
féminines de vélizy pour leur première
rencontre de nationale 3 les bélizienne
en recevait ce dimanche 4 octobre le
paris volley de rencontre maîtrisée du
début à la fin par les joueuses locales
encore en rodage score est sans appel
3-0 25-18 dans la première manche 25 17
dans la seconde et 25-21 dans la
dernière très heureuse d'avoir gagné ce
premier match de la saison
ça fait plaisir plutôt satisfait de la
prestation des joueuses effectivement on
pensait que l'équipe adverse a est un
peu plus dure à jouer et en fait on a
réussi à hausser notre niveau de jeu
donc plutôt ça est très satisfait pour
un premier match de l'année après six
mois sans choix c'est très content après
cette performance le club de vélizy
pointe à la cinquième place du
classement mais le club compte un match
en moins sur les leaders
si on peut continuer à jouer ça signifie
voilà une bonne entrée en matière moins
de pression par la suite parce que du
coup on engage tout de suite avec un bon
résultat on est contre les capable de
faire des choses donc sa annonce que du
positif on sait que théoriquement combo
dame a fini l'année dernière on va jouer
les équipes sens est plus forte sur le
début de saison donc c'est pour ça qu'on
est content de ce match là parce que
effectivement c'était censé être une des
plus grosses équipes que ça maintenant
voilà les et poule 2 les équipes du nord
risa plus rigoureux statut prête on
verra sera surprise du chef
prochain match pour le club de vélizy ce
dimanche 11 octobre à 16 heures sur le
terrain de liévinois l'équipe qui a
remporté ses deux premiers matches de la
saison
[Applaudissements]